hello my name is matthias from datatab
and in this video i'd like to show you
how you can easily calculate a linear
regression
online with datatab so first of all
you need to visit datatab.net afterwards
click on the statistics calculator
and because we want to calculate a
regression we need to select
regression if you want to use your own
data
you need to clear this table so click on
clear table
afterwards you can copy your own data
i've prepared a small example so
simply select the data and copy the data
into this table in this example
we have the body weight of a person the
height
the age and the gender and the aim is
to predict the weight based on the
height
the age and the gender so our dependent
variable
is a weight and the independent
variables
are the height the h and the gender
okay let's calculate the linear
regression with data tab
so we can select the dependent variable
and
the independent variables as a dependent
variable
we want to use the weight so we simply
click
on weight as independent variables we
want to use the
height the h and gender
and now we will get the results for the
linear regression
at the top we can see the r square and
the adjusted
square and here we can
see the anova which simply tell us if
our
overall model is significant or not
in this case because it's smaller than
0.05
the model is significant and at the end
we get our coefficients so we get the
unstandardized coefficients
and the standardized coefficients we get
the values here
and there and also we can see
if the coefficients are significant or
not
if you have for example nominal variable
which has
more than two characteristics then
data tab will automatically create the
dummy variables
further at the right side you will get
the scatter diagram
and if you have the premium version data
tab
will check for you all the conditions if
you are able to calculate
a linear regression so
okay i hope you liked this video if you
have questions
simply leave us a comment bye and see
you the next time